like you just go airbnb now right oh
yeah yeah yeah
because you know what i started to think
about dude you know what i really
started to think about
would you if someone was like hey man
use mattress for sale would you be like
i'm not buying that [ __ ] mattress
never do you know in a hotel that's all
used it's you're sleeping on
other people's [ __ ] bets yeah you ever
seen when they do like the black lights
dude i brought one oh you did so i did a
show
i did a show where they were like you
travel one of the things we want you to
do is bring your
black light to your room the black light
so the curtains are gross but the
bathroom walls
it's like people are coming and just
throwing it just busting just [ __ ]
but just like
throwing it at the wall i'm like
shooting ropes
but i've never been that excited in a
hotel bathroom to [ __ ] shoot
i'm jumping over the sink yeah the the
dirtiest thing is the phones and the
remote controls
nobody thinks about that but they never
watch the remotes or the phones
i got everyone's [ __ ] grimy hands if
they're doing god's nose why
oh you know what [ __ ] in there and then
picking up the phone back hey how's it
going baby you don't
send me a water yeah yeah i i need more
towels
and then you're picking up the phone
they don't clean those the i don't [ __ ]
with hotels anymore no you can't thank
god
i'm at a level now right i don't thank
god i don't have to do hotels
see i don't mind a hotel man but a nice
hotel
but if you're like if the black light is
like
look if you're staying in a place where
people are jerking off in the mirror
over the sink where you brush your teeth
yeah
here's the thing papa they're doing it
even in four seasons though
that's just especially in four seasons
yeah dude the freaks of four seasons the
white rich freaks in there they're just
used to having people clean up for
yeah or it's like the the celebrity
who's staying there
you know dude i stayed in a hotel once
in atlanta right
and this is again back before i was
staying in places where this wouldn't
happen
and i sat down and had like a living
room and a in a bedroom and i was like
oh that's fancy this yeah and you know
what i mean
and so i sat down on the couch and i was
wearing shorts not too often am i
wearing shorts
b i've never seen the insurance there's
a reason do you want have you ever seen
how pale my
legs are yeah they're pale and it's thin
right yeah
yeah so
i sat down on the couch and i felt like
a jab in my leg and my hamstring and i
was like what the hell tell me it was a
needle
my man it was a someone had picked
the toenail off their big toe and stuck
it in the couch so it was sticking
straight out oh wow
so and i it jabbed the back of my leg
now i didn't take it out of the couch
because i was like if this happened to
me
it's going to have to pay forward yeah
yeah but it was one of the grossest that
it was right around the time where i was
like
i'm picking my own hotel from here on
out yeah yeah it's tough i think the
only hotel stands
hotel emma in san antonio that's my
favorite hotel
outside batman especially like pandemic
air when i was torn down pandemic hotels
were such a bummer
yeah there's no room service they they
cut down the staff
everybody's depressed everybody's in
masks so i'm just like oh
yeah and they're like if you could wash
your own towels you're like [ __ ]
oh they don't clean the room nobody's
cleaning the room
[ __ ] this yeah yeah yeah but some of the
airbnb's getting a little dicey like we
got one in austin
there's i traveled like a squad there's
like eight of us so we got one in austin
uh and pictures looked sick but dude it
was straight up somebody's
somebody straight up family home dude
there was the kids money in the piggy
bank no yeah and
uh my so i the one thing about those
houses i don't like
if if you have your family pictures on
the wall i can't [ __ ] with that i can't
be in somebody's house like but they it
was like
they just and it was these doctors we
found these like indian doctors and
their whole family is there like
it's six kids or whatever so there's all
these rooms but it's all their kids
stuff is in there so that means like
hey kids someone booked it for next
weekend so we gotta get our [ __ ]
now here's the thing we gotta get our
[ __ ] and go to the guest room
up right there so no it specifically
said do not go to the
the guest room and i'm like why the [ __ ]
why would they care for the guest room
well that's because all of them move
there while we're there so it was like
houses here detached
guest house and they're all in the guest
house so they're
doing their thing like looking at us no
no no
sometimes yeah so the actual homeowners
were staying in the backyard yeah not
chilling no
no first of all again postmates
deliveries and [ __ ] we're like what are
you what's happening right now i
i i don't know about you man but i don't
think that i could go back and live
in my house because first of all i don't
know what people are doing in my kids
beds
that's what's weird like you got comics
in your kid's bed and you left your kid
left this piggy bank
and then the kids like like they had
their medications still in the drawers
and [ __ ] so obviously
i'm going through all the medications
like is there anything good in here
there's any drugs you know it's funny by
the way
um so you know i've known joe diaz for a
long time
and he and i when we were doing drugs
and didn't have any money we used to
leave ious in my son's piggy bank
and so years later when we i finally
went through there i'm like let's see
how much money you got
i found like four hundred dollars in
ious for me
it was like i owe you 20 bucks dog yeah
sorry
sorry dog i needed some blow dog yeah
he was like what are these like where
the [ __ ] this money you might want to
keep that one
that's 60 bucks from uncle joey there
uncle joey was on a bender man
used your cash